on l'a 72 degrés pas de panique c'est la
température du gazon tendu je n'ai
volontairement entassées au fond du
jardin
d'où vient cette chaleur nous sommes
pourtant à l'ombre et bien depuis
plusieurs jours des micro organismes des
grains de la matière organique et se
multiplient cette activité comme
n'importe quels exercices génère de la
chaleur qui sous cet épais manteau
végétal ne parvient pas à s'échapper au
contraire la température monte
c'est pas plus mal au delà de 70 degrés
un bon nombre de microbes pathogènes ne
résiste pas il y en a un je mettrais
bien là dedans il ya même des ingénieurs
qui songent à utiliser ce phénomène pour
chauffer des logements en tout cas c'est
suffisant pour chauffer une capsule de
des confiné à les ados mais n'oubliez
pas nous sommes confinés
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleu vous pouvez également voir ou
revoir celle des jours précédents
cliquant sur le côté gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour et
pour être sûr de ne louper aucune et
bien abonnez vous et activer la petite
cloche à demain et n'oubliez pas nous
sommes toujours confiné et on reste en
lien